good morning it's seven o'clock you're
watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster and today well no
signs of the sleaze row simmering down
forcing new denials from downing street
this morning
working pension secretary will be on the
show shortly along with the shadow
health secretary
now a man for all seasons 2012 hero greg
rutherford joins us later to discuss how
he's hoping to make
olympic history and
may the fourth be with you the auction
date to sell off
star wars treasures like this
love that we'll get a glimpse of what's
going under the hammer
it is tuesday the 27th of april
race for aid uk supplies arrive in india
as sky news visits hospitals going to
drastic lengths to treat patients
they've had to build tents in the car
park to cope with the over spill all
these people
are suffering from coronavirus all of
them
need oxygen gross distortions
downing street hits back at new claims
about alleged comments from the prime
minister
a holidays on the horizon the greek
tourism office suggests to sky news the
uk
could be edging closer to issuing a
health pass
for international travel
the cost of miscarriage calls for action
to better support the mental health of
parents
ufo why space command is investigating
this supposedly close encounter
which triggered a false alarm
and it's looking cooler and cloudy
across many areas today with some
showers
but some spots will have sunshine and
water still
find out where the sunshine and warmth
will be with me later
in the programme
a very good morning to you in india now
the epicenter of the global covid
pandemic the need for medical supplies
in
hospitals beds has grown so desperate
patients are being treated in makeshift
tents in car parks
more than 300 000 new coronavirus cases
have been recorded for a sixth
consecutive day
with another 2770
deaths reported although health experts
believe the real tally
is far higher from new delhi our special
correspondent
alex crawford reports
the struggle to save lives is now tied
up with the struggle to find oxygen
and every person in this hospital is
part of that fight
and across the indian capital it's
almost an
hourly battle emotionally we are drained
we have not seen so many mortalities
in our icu as well as in our near and
dear ones
i get maybe uh around 50 calls every day
somebody's asking for beds somebody's
asking for cylinders somebody's asking
for drugs
we don't have anything available
and patients are dying
india's still reporting global record
high numbers for coronavirus cases
and they're struggling now
is requiring at least 15 liters a minute
that means
at this rate every three hours is a
struggle for us to arrange for the neo
auxin cylinders
they've got nearly double the number of
patients in this hospital
and they're expecting worse to come the
situation is critical right now
this pandemic is the worst we have ever
seen till now
and these two weeks are going to be a
hell for us
i want you to have a look at this
because it's hard to illustrate
the scale of a problem with a country
the size of india
and with the population of india but
this is just what
one hospital has done to cope with a
rising number of
coronavirus patients and it keeps on
rising they've had to build tents
in the car park to cope with the
overspill all these people
are suffering from coronavirus all of
them
need oxygen they can't take in any more
and these are the lucky ones who managed
to get help
international help including from
britain is on its way but it can't come
soon enough with patients struggling for
breath and worrying if their lifelines
will run out
sometimes this is working sometimes
this other cylinder is finishing
sometimes two hours here they are
picking
so they are
nearing the oxygen level
though it is immediate like it should be
more so this is the problem
india's calamity is the rest of the
world too
with a new more virulent variant called
a double mutation
and doctors saying they're seeing
alarming resistance to medicines and
vaccines
the double mutant it bypasses everything
even the medicines are not very
effective on that
so the medicines which were very helpful
in the earlier
last week last week which we used to
give in the mild cases it doesn't seem
to work now
there are many more people needing much
more oxygen
and they're having to beg barter and buy
from wherever
i'm buying oxygen at the rate of gold
you know it has the situation come to
that level it was like 20
22 rupees per kg oxygen and today i
sanctioned for 50 rupees
per kg and the black marketing is
happening
render severe injection which is like
4000 rupees or 2000 also
people are buying at 40 000 rupees
the government is urging its citizens
not to panic and not to hoard but the
oxygen demand has risen around 20
nationally with some hospitals coming
within minutes of running out of
supplies
so they're not prepared to listen right
now alex corford
sky news in new delhi
well the first consignments of uk aid
have now arrived in india
these are the latest pictures of the
equipment being unloaded
late last night the foreign secretary
said international collaboration
is key to fighting this global threat
and now if you've seen the papers this
morning they're all
full of the latest sort of allegations
sleaze allegations really is the only
way to describe it
against the prime minister against
number 10 let's talk to the working
pension secretary
terese coffey who's here it's good to
see you good morning
i mean look when you look at the papers
this morning i mean
it's depressing stuff how do you feel
about all of all of this
well the pm answered a lot of questions
yesterday um continues to
uh say that uh we our main priorities
get on the job whether that's about
being tackling the virus or indeed about
getting
young people into work uh which we're
doing through kickstart
uh but i think it's just part of the
ongoing uh aspects of
uh recognizing there's a number of uh
different inquiries underway cabinet
secretary spoke to parliament yesterday
as well
and frankly we just uh our focuses on
other things i think is the best way to
say i mean do you think mistakes have
been made somewhere along the way
well undoubtedly the um you know things
that we were discussing actually with
the chief scientist
and uh chief medical officer you know as
was suggested perhaps last year when
certain assumptions were made about how
the virus might be transmitted we have a
different understanding of that now so
there's different
elements that have gone along the way
but the key thing is we've now got 33
million people vaccinated with their
first dose nearly 13 million with their
second dose
uh so it's all been about trying to make
sure that we tackle
uh the coronavirus and actually get on
with the road map to recovery
uh because by trying to have also saved
lives we're actually been trying to save
livelihoods and we now need to get the
economy really flowing again
uh look away from the prime minister if
you like but on
on a personal level to you if someone
ever said
you know let the bodies pile high are
they comments you could ever personally
condone the prime minister says he
didn't say them and he said that
i think yesterday i think to sky uh and
so yeah i take the prime minister on his
word but but away from the prime
minister if anybody else said it could
you ever condone it
well i'm not aware that any politician
has said anything like that so
indeed any other person i'm aware of but
there's an element here about to say
trying to keep on with the main uh task
at hand
uh we've got through this uh challenging
time we're still not out of it
that's why we're still encouraging
people to take up their vaccines but
also the work like kickstarter getting
young people back into work
yeah look i know we're going to talk
more about kickstarter in just a moment
but
in terms of some of the other
allegations floating about and to do
with the flat in number 11.
what's what's going on with what's going
on with that it's a confusing picture
well the prime minister has said that he
has paid for the uh redevelopment that
happened
um he's asked simon case who's the
highest civil servant in the land to
undertake a review of exactly what
happened simon was not the cabinet
secretary
when all this started so it's important
that simon's been allowed to do that and
he said that he would
share that with the select committee in
parliament but the point is that
uh i guess for a number of people it's
just uh while we're trying to make sure
that we get through and tackling the
virus and get people back into work
i don't think the majority of the bishop
public are in any way interested about
some wallpaper or sofas or something
like that
so i do understand that we need to keep
moving on as it were in terms of uh
what's going to make a difference to
people's lives in the years ahead
yeah i mean charles walker um deputy
chair of the
1922 committee said last night you know
to paraphrase him couldn't give two figs
about
who paid for the flat as long as it
wasn't his constituents
well i think it's important that uh you
know the prime minister will make
the declarations in the usual way these
sorts of things often get tidy up in
something called the annual accounts
uh which get published by departments
every year so
it's just uh the right declarations will
be made the prime minister paid for it
personally
and meantime he's out leading the
government
in trying to get back on the road
roadmap to recovery and i think we're
making good progress on that
i mean i know you know to this point all
these allegations have
have been denied but i mean do you
accept there is a growing
perception of sleaze i mean this there
was a
there's a poll in in i think it's the
eye this morning
um saying that you know public opinion
is shifting i mean this is the damages
it whether whether or not any
allegations are true
the perception seems to be sticking what
i do see is uh being out on the
doorsteps uh campaigning which i have
been doing myself during this
campaign people are generally optimistic
they're pleased with
how we're now getting on they're excited
by the prospect of
getting this virus properly under
control recognizing it
won't go away forever but uh seeing the
say the number of vaccines
uh out there and actually life starting
to come back to normal
and so it's about uh i i genuinely
believe people are just more interested
in getting on with their daily lives
and the actions that we're taking to
help them to get back to more of a new
normal as it were post covered
what do you think dominic cummings is
playing at i don't know if you if you
had any dealings with him particularly
when
he was still working in number 10 but
what's he playing at
um i don't know he was an adviser to the
prime minister
he didn't really have a lot to do with
dwp i think
i had one message about kickstart
funnily enough last year and that's
about it
in my interaction which i think is a
reflection of how with
department work and pensions have really
got on with the task at hand
and spending uh an extra seven billion
pounds on welfare in the last year
because many people have turned to
benefits for the first time
we were able to meet that challenge but
our challenge is now to
recognize nearly a million people have
lost their jobs many
millions more 5 million being protected
by the furlough scheme and we're
particularly focusing on young people
and i'm pleased that over 16 000 young
people have started their kickstart role
but we've created and approved nearly
200 000 jobs to be filled
over the next year so it's a really
exciting time
but that's happening more quickly now as
we move along the road map to recovery
but i mean look i i get that there is a
need to focus on what is happening now
and what the government is working on at
the moment but
there is some concern me from william
hague former leader
of course who said with the with the
prospect of dominic cummings giving
evidence before
one of the committees william hague said
um in the times i think it was it would
be a mistake to dismiss
these allegations as a fleeting problem
dominic cummings he says he's likely to
turn up to this committee with a trail
of digital evidence
well a lot of people will have seen
dominic coming to the first time ever
last year
uh when he gave a press conference in
the rose garden number 10.
they'll have come to their own views i'm
sure the public um
and meanwhile the prime minister
continues to get on with the key things
that really do matter to people the
people's priorities so
you know there's an element here that we
have a real level of transparency within
government
we publish aspects about on a quarterly
basis about our meetings that we have
those sorts of things
so it's it's important that we say keep
focused parliament
does its job of scrutiny which is doing
uh and we uh
as i say really focus on things like
helping people get back into work well
and in terms of that and the kickstart
you know i think it was about two-thirds
of those who've lost their jobs during
the pandemica
are under 25. it is very difficult for
those people to get places in employment
16 500 places is impressive in itself
but
there's still a you know we're talking
half a million people here so
you're absolutely right stephen and i've
got to get people back up and running
quickly haven't we you're absolutely
right stephen i'm conscious
um with aspects of the lockdown it's
proving challenging to get some of these
jobs
uh kind of underway but we've seen a
real uptick in the number of employers
opening their doors getting young people
in
giving that sort of training that job
experience
later today i'm going to a leading
retailer again to look at how
they've taken on nearly 300 people and
they're going to be learning a variety
of tasks
and opportunity experiencing
opportunities during their time
with the retailers so you know we are
trying to provide
opportunities for people so they get
that first first foot on the ladder of
getting back into
work what's what's the the the appeal to
employers for this as you try and get
more people
into this scheme as businesses reopen
well kickstart in particular is um
actually the flagship scheme of our plan
for jobs more broadly where we're trying
to help people of all ages
but employers get basically wages
subsidised
25 hours free employment in return it's
a mutual benefit they have to provide
that
sort of real role but also the
employability support so young people
are ready to get the next
hopefully long-term job can i just ask
you quickly about uh
nazanin zagari ratcliffe i mean hugely
distressing for her and her family and
friends
about what's happening the foreign
secretary says the uk is going to do all
it can
what can we do what options are on the
table well i think that we just keep
making representations in the standard
diplomatic way i'm conscious that
you know this is decision of the iran
regime the iran iranian
judiciary system and just as we have
tried to support this family along the
way we will keep doing so and keep
making the case
on why we don't think this is
appropriate and in order to try and get
has been reunited with her family as
quickly as possible
there's coffee it's good to see you this
morning thank you
just a reminder that if you want to
catch up on any of the interview
with therese or watch the program when
you're out and about this morning then
you can do so just by
getting on the mobile app or our website
go to the live blog to watch the program
and you can
catch up uh with the interviews on my
twitter as well that's at sky
stephen okay let's talk to our political
correspondent kate mccann who's with us
now what do you think kate
i think it's really interesting isn't it
because we've been talking about these
allegations
against boris johnson the prime minister
against david cameron former prime
minister now for
how long a couple of weeks at least
maybe over a month
and it's still there it's still the main
chunk of an interview when a government
minister comes on
any political programme and that's a
problem for the conservatives because
it's now become a narrative and that's
what labour is hoping for that's why
they keep talking about tory sleeves
what the conservative party has to do is
try and get out from under that and you
heard to raise coffee there trying to do
that trying to say you know it's all
about moving on
she actually did acknowledge that there
will be some things that the government
did get wrong and that will of course
form part
of an investigation and an inquiry later
on but one of the most fascinating bits
for me and maybe that's just because i'm
a bit of a westminster geek
was that bill at the end where she
talked about dominic cummings and you
said you know dominic comments is going
to come before a committee is going to
have lots of evidence
and she said well the public saw dominic
cummings for the first time
when he did that press conference after
of course barnard castle
that's trying to undermine his
credibility and i just wonder whether
that might be something that we start to
see more of
as we go through the next couple of
weeks okay kate thank you
now at half past seven we're going to
ask the chair of the foreign affairs
select committee tom toucan hat what
next for nazanin
zagari radcliffe after she was sentenced
to another year
in prison in iran
true lava the icelandic couple who had
their wedding in front of an erupting
volcano very brave and
you want a big night i'll give you a big
night
a half-past nine how london theaters are
scouting out the next generation of
talent
while looking ahead to the next stage of
lockdown lifting
now could a summer holiday to greece
soon be on the horizon
the country's tourism office has
suggested things could be moving in
the right direction well let's talk to
aisha zahid who's in the newsroom for us
this morning a lot of people will be
rubbing their hands
in glee at the prospect of this what's
been said aisha
they certainly will be but it's
important to note that this comes with
confusion
as well now as you said the greek
tourism board have said they will be
willing to open their borders to british
travelers
as long as they can prove that they have
been vaccinated through official
documentation
and in a statement they said our
understanding is that a health pass will
be forthcoming
now it's not clear what this health pass
will be the times today reported that
greece will be accepting the handwritten
nhs vaccine card until there is a
digital format
and other countries like portugal have
said this won't be enough for them due
to forgery risks
now the uk tourism minister nigel
huddleston has said that britain
is working with the eu on vaccine
passports for travel
and that's as far as we know now
according to the roadmap out of lockdown
non-essential travel will be permitted
it could be permitted from 17th of may
through a traffic light system
with green listed countries not
requiring a quarantine period
while amber and redlisted countries do
now there's still no clear indication of
which countries will be in which list
greece and portugal have said they're
confident that they will be
on the green list due to the coveted
situation in their countries
but we've got no clarification on this
and foreign travel has been disrupted
for more than a year now
people are going to be more keen than
ever to take their holidays
and with that date approaching we've
only got three weeks now
they're certainly going to be looking
for answers i said thank you
let's look at some of the main stories
for you this morning
and coronavirus fines are muddled
discriminatory
and unfair and should be reviewed that's
according to mps and peers on the joint
committee for human rights who say
all 85 000 fines that have been issued
need to be reviewed let's have a look at
the latest coronavirus figures for you
today
and 2064 new cases have been reported in
the most recent 24-hour period
with six more deaths that means the
total number of people who've died
it is 127 434.
another 79 695 people have had their
first vaccine
260 801 have had their second
that means more than 46.65 million
injections have been given out
across the uk
an application has been made to pardon
george floyd for a previous drugs
conviction
mr floyd was arrested in houston in 2004
by officer
gerald goins for selling 10 worth of
crack
goings now faces a series of charges
including
two for murder after a couple died in
the drugs raid in 2019.
more than 160 drugs convictions tied to
the officer have since been dismissed
the u.s justice department is to open a
sweeping probe
into policing in louisville kentucky
following the death
of emergency worker briana taylor ms
taylor had been studying to become a
nurse and was shot
in bed by officers as part of a drugs
raid
no drugs were ever found in a house it's
the second
investigation into a police force
announced by the biden administration
this week just remind you that you can
catch up on the day's big business news
and interviews on the ian king business
podcast which is available on the sky
news app
or wherever you get your podcasts
now there are calls to do more to help
support parents who've been through a
miscarriage
new figures suggest the cost to society
from subsequent mental health issues is
more than
400 million pounds becky cottrell
reports
laura bradshaw was glowing on her
wedding day but as happy as she was to
be marrying her husband chris
it was not an easy day for them both one
month earlier
laura had a miscarriage i think
for me personally it was a huge shock to
have a miscarriage i've obviously
i know about miscarriage and i i've seen
about it
on you know i don't know various things
but you don't ever really think it's
going to happen to you
and because no one really speaks about
it it's when it does happen
you're just so isolated and you just
feel so lonely
laura's had three more miscarriages
since then but only after the third was
she eligible to have tests
through the nhs to determine whether
there were any underlying medical issues
it's yeah it's really really difficult
and it feels like
because they're saying you have to have
three like it's not a big deal
it feels like they're saying we don't
really care come back
when you've you know had more the
charity tommy's found that parents who
go through a miscarriage are twice as
likely to experience depression
and four times as likely to attempt
suicide and the risk of a future
miscarriage
increases by 10 percent each time a
woman loses a pregnancy
the study also found black women are 40
percent more likely to have a
miscarriage than white women
for long miscarriage has been seen as a
isolated
physical event it's not it has got
profound implications in terms of future
pregnancy risks
such as an increase in the risk of
preterm birth
and it has profound implications in
terms of the
psychological effects that couples
who've had miscarriages suffer
for example post-traumatic stress
disorder
tommy's estimate that one in four
pregnancies end in a miscarriage
the charities calling for better care
for women after their first miscarriage
and more mental health support for women
and couples
laura is finally receiving treatment
that she hopes will improve her chances
of having a child
but she says she shouldn't have had to
wait four years and
four miscarriages to get to this point
becky cottrell
sky news essex
well this is sky news breakfast let's
have a check on the weather for you this
morning naz
how's it going to be today say please
stay bright
there will be some brightness stephen
yes that's uh correct across southern
areas where actually
it is going to still be quite mild but
elsewhere although a mild start it's
generally
cool and cloudy with some showers
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning so generally speaking we
are going to be seeing cooler conditions
for many areas for the next few days
it's going to be
largely cloudy as well still a bit of
brightness here and there but also
quite wet at times there will be scatter
showers that could be locally heavy and
perhaps even more persistent rain across
parts of the south
uh towards the weekend and the return of
overnight frost so
a real difference compared to last week
to begin with this morning it's not so
cold compared to previous mornings
because we've had cloud cover overnight
so it's quite a dull start to the day
for many areas
a little bit of brightness here and
there but generally speaking quite
cloudy there are some showers scattered
across
the north of ireland northern ireland
over northern england towards the
northeast perhaps even the north wales
and across scotland more persistent
spells are rain mainly across the
northeast there but
across central and southern areas it's a
chilly start but it's sunny
and locally there's a frost in some
spots now going into this afternoon
we're going to see little change on the
story really it's going to stay mostly
cloudy there will be some
breaks in the cloud here and there so
there will be a bit of brightness but
in between those bright or sunny spells
there will be showers dotted about and
some of them could be locally heavy as
they become more widespread across
much of ireland northern ireland wales
northern england perhaps eastern england
later as well
and that rain across scotland will
slowly edge its way further
southwards as well so the northeast
becoming a bit dry later but a brisk
wind there but the south sunny dry and
warm
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
yes thank you now of course i love a
space story so have a look
at this it's impressive picture space
debris appears to have
narrowly missed four spacex astronauts
shortly after they settled into orbit
last friday it's a sizable chunk as well
isn't it
the crew were ordered back into their
spacesuits having been worn there was a
risk of their capsule colliding with the
object but although the debris looks to
have flown close by in these pictures
there was in fact no threat of collision
and the review is underway
into what they're now tagging as a false
alarm
now just a day later the spacex team
docked with the international space
station
the number of astronauts on board rising
to 11. it's the biggest number to be in
the station in a decade
of course it's about 260 miles above
the earth and uh at the minute we think
above the indian ocean
to keep a close eye on where it is it's
always good when you can see it passing
in the skies
overhead still to come for you this
morning
we're going to be talking about nazanin
zagari ratcliff and her extended prison
sentence we'll talk to the chair
of the foreign affairs select committee
in just a moment
there are things we all take for granted
as the rivers and tides flow
the sun will rise the wind will blow
and the earth will spin but are we now
spiraling into a climate crisis
which cannot be avoided no one can
predict the impact that it's going to
have
close to the peak here this is really
the moment it's true
expected to be hit very hard indeed what
can be done
to reverse the spiral the daily climate
show on sky news
will look for the answers
you know it's not exactly a zoomed
in sort of ceremony because they didn't
want that from the start but then
you know to have the the cameras set up
in different parts of the world in
london and paris and to have some people
be able to
to be there and and show their presence
uh was
really wonderful and in the room itself
which was in union station which you can
see
illuminated behind me it's a beautiful
historic building in downtown los
angeles never hosted anything
fabulous like the oscars before but they
they had the setup so that
the nominees would rotate in and be in
the audience
so you didn't have those usual cutaway
shots of
george clooney sitting there skulking or
chuckling or
uh you know the major stars that are
always there just
in the room to add that sort of uh
that sort of energy but it was a
different kind of energy it was an
homage to
just the films that were nominated in
the films that won
there was so much more diversity last
night in fact those
two women being nominated for best
director and one winning and being the
first woman
of color to win uh was was
a very very different sense than the
oscars of days gone by
so yes a different ceremony but it was
a show of determination for hollywood
that's kind of coming out of its shell
putting the gowns back on getting out of
the sweatpants
putting on a little lipstick because
there were no masks that we could see
in the camera shots they were treating
it as a movie set
they said that when the cameras were off
the masks went back on everyone had been
tested vaccinated
sitting far enough apart to be safe but
hollywood has been back in business
shooting movies and tv shows and and
for the last few months as far as we
know with
very strict protocols and those were all
in place in the theater last night
[Music]
[Music]
now as nazanin zagari ratcliffe faces up
to
another year in jail the foreign
secretary has called
an iranian court's decision to impose a
new sentence
totally inhumane and wholly unjustified
meanwhile nazanin's husband richard
ratcliffe says she's being used as a
political
bargaining chip well let's talk to the
chair of the foreign affairs select
committee tom toucanhack good to see you
this morning look we're talking to
terese coffee just a few minutes ago and
she said the government is
is applying as much diplomatic pressure
as it's
as it can clearly that's not enough what
more can be done
well i think the uh aspect of the law
that was changed yesterday introducing
corruption
as one of the means of sanctions is an
important change i think it means that
we can sanction
many of the corrupt business people who
are supporting this appalling regime
and i think we need to expose quite
clearly and in every means possible
that this is a regime that is using a
mother
as a hostage in order to extract
leverage that is an act of
complete barbarity it goes against
everything in islamic law
in humanitarian action it's it's
absolutely horrific
but it's again it is very difficult to
know quite what can be done i mean even
if you can apply
sanctions on on wealthy people propping
up the regime that
it's no guarantee of action and even if
it is
it could take quite some time no there
is no guarantee of action that's true
it is the decision of the mullahs and
their acolytes
in tehran who have decided to hold on to
a young mother and separate her from her
family that is their decision it is a
decision
by ayatollahs claiming to act in the
name of the iranian people they're not
they're tyrants and they're holding
an entire country hostage not just a a
young mother
and and it's an act of complete
barbarity so
you're right we can't force uh the
ayatollahs to change their mind we can't
force the revolutionary guard commanders
to change their mind
but what we can do is we can make it
very plain
uh by revealing where they're getting
their money from how they're stealing
off the iranian people
and and where it's all going it's going
into their pockets and it's going into
wars like the war in syria
look what is she being held
for in terms of this idea of being a
bargaining chip
what what is the regime trying to
achieve
well it's very difficult to know they
claim that it's about a 400 million
pound debt
the british government absolutely agrees
that it owes to the iranian government
the only reason it hasn't been paid back
is because the iranian government is
sanctioned when the american government
gave back a similar sum a number of
years ago the iranian government
released six americans and a few months
later took another six
so this is simply a means of doing
business by the ayatollahs
and a way of extracting leverage on
other countries and by the way
there's a german who's being held there
was an australian this is how the
iranian government
behaves it's not just about the debt and
so settling the debt i'm afraid
that may bring temporary release would
not be a long-term solution
no but it may bring well temporary
release in some respects it may bring
permanent release for nazanee
it could do and you know many of us
support uh settling the debt but that's
a separate matter unless of course you
think it's an acceptable form
of uh international uh diplomacy to take
hostages
we happen to think that's a bad way of
conducting business
and i i would hope that in fact i would
be absolutely certain that your viewers
think it's an absolutely horrific way of
conducting business
and so the iranian government needs to
decide whether it wants to behave like a
mafia hit squad
or like a responsible government and you
talked about the foreign secretary
and imposing sanctions on countries that
have
sort of severe levels of corruption now
no one's suggesting it's quite the same
here in the uk but the
the sleaze allegations are certainly
causing uh
i mean they're all over the papers on
every paper this morning how
concerned are you by what we're seeing
reported
well i think integrity matters in
politics and i think these allegations
are serious but let's not
uh overlook the fact that this is in
many ways an internal dispute
between two people now i hope very much
that uh
the accusations will cease and that we
can get back to
doing what we need to do which is to
recover after the most extraordinarily
painful
year for many many people we need a real
recovery in this country
we need a boom of jobs and growth
not just because we need to rebuild the
country but we need to build rebuild
communities we need people to come back
together to look to enterprise to look
to opportunity
and to show that the uk really is the
place to do business look i've
you know whether you're investing in
newcastle or glasgow or bristol or
belfast it doesn't matter we need this
country to be booming
because this country is a brilliant
place to do business
and that means that the government needs
to be focusing on that
well yes but i mean and that's all
that's all well and good a lot of people
would agree with you but
you know it's it's it's only going to be
seen as a good place to do business and
a good place to do a lot of other stuff
if we think those in power are acting
with integrity now there are questions
as to whether the prime minister is
well as i say there's a lot of gossip
going on at the moment i look forward to
the investigations that my parliamentary
colleagues have launched releasing
their findings william rag my fellow
chair of a committee he chairs public
administration
is already looking into this so you know
we'll find out the answers as soon as
he's done that
but my focus is absolutely on making
sure this country
booms now my focus as you know as chair
of the foreign affairs committee is
making sure that we have partnerships
and relationships with countries around
the world
with whom we can work together on
everything from vaccine diplomacy to
trade
so i hope that we're going to be
building in the kind of partnerships we
need to make sure that this country
sees the opportunities for every citizen
in every community
tom toucan good to talk to you thank you
well let's just bring more on those
sleaze claims faced by the government
and indeed the prime minister the times
has more allegations this morning
including that the prime minister told
aides he would rather let coronavirus
rip than impose a second lockdown
downing street has described the reports
as gross distortions
well earlier we spoke to the work and
pension secretary therese coffey
she admitted the government's
understanding of how to tackle the virus
has changed over time
well undoubtedly the um you know things
that we were discussing
actually with the chief scientist and
chief medical officer
you know as was suggested perhaps last
year when
certain assumptions were made about how
the virus might be transmitted we have a
different understanding of that now so
there's different elements
that have gone along the way but the key
thing is we've now got 33
million people vaccinated with their
first dose nearly 13 million with their
second dose
so it's all been about trying to make
sure that we tackle uh the coronavirus
and actually get on
with the roadmap to recovery
well let's talk to the shadow health
secretary jonathan ashworth who's here
in the studio good to see you this
morning
look therese coffee's saying yeah i mean
there are still
lessons to be learned in how we handle
the coronavirus pandemic i mean is that
an indication as to say well perhaps
some of the language has
you know has been has been wrong do you
think i mean she denies that
in one sense but clearly an indication
that things do need to be looked at
again
well there definitely are lessons to be
learned i mean we're still not paying
people decent sick pay so they can
isolate themselves
for example i think that is a monstrous
failing in the government's response
but the question is did boris johnson
say these
sickening crass words about allowing
bodies
to pile up there's more sources telling
very respected journalists that he
definitely said it apparently shouted it
in anger
from his office i mean there'll be so
many people who have lost a mum or
a grandma or a father in this crisis who
never got the chance to say a proper
goodbye never got the opportunity of a
proper family funeral and
those remarks were just oh well they
were disgusting really weren't they
and i think it is serious if there's
more and more sources telling newspapers
and journalists
that he definitely said it but you know
he's denied saying it michael gove
who was in the room at the time said he
he never heard those words
so who do we believe well i mean this is
why it's slightly bewildering isn't it
because
he well my gov didn't entirely deny just
that he wasn't in the room but
you've got you have got very serious
respected political journalists that
in the newspapers and on the broad and
on broadcast channels saying they've
definitely got sources who have
who are telling them he definitely said
it and he shouted it
down the corridor from his office in
anger
the key thing is that the handling of
this crisis
hasn't gone well there are things that
we got
desperately wrong like not paying sick
pay not having the proper ppe
for nhs staff early on not protecting
our care homes
where so many people died so i'm
delaying going into the lockdowns i mean
that's what this is about isn't it
johnson didn't want to put us into the
lockdowns
his former right hand man dominic
cummings who he brought into the heart
of downing street
he's letting it be known that he wanted
the lockdowns sooner
this is this is such a mess at a time
when the country
is in crisis politicians the government
they've got to be better than this
what you're saying you're believing you
believe what dominic cummings has to say
the man who
you know so you say he wanted locked
down soon he was the one who was
tripping off to barnard castle i mean
you can
you can't you can't disbelieve him on
one thing and believe them on them
well in some ways it's difficult to know
who to believe because it's such a mess
isn't it
i mean i've been talking about the fact
that we've got 400 000 people
uh waiting over a year for treatment now
that's people waiting longer for cancer
treatment for
waiting longer with heart disease we've
got the highest weights on record now
for children
with eating disorders i mean these are
the issues i want the prime minister and
the cabinet to focus on
but you've got boris johnson ringing up
journalists himself
to slag off dominic cummings i mean it's
crazy
when the country is in such a mess that
this is what they are
focusing on this fighting and backbiting
surely the country deserves better than
this well well
a lot of people may agree with you so
why then are you so determined as a
party to
to get people to focus on his flat
refurbishment of all things i mean why
does that matter at this time when we're
told there's going to be an
investigation but we're also told that
he's paid for this himself well i think
i think it does matter because we know
he wanted to upgrade his flat because he
didn't think the john lewis furniture uh
was good enough i mean i think john
lewis furniture is pretty pretty good
actually pretty posh stuff but yeah but
the second thing
they've given thirty thousand pounds a
year to make changes that's
excellent but he wanted a more lavish
upgrade of the flat
but yesterday he said he paid for it
overnight we've had reports that the
tory party head office paid for it
we know they were asking uh business
people
to fund it so we want we need to know
whether he's had a loan from somebody
uh uh is he paying it back to them is he
paying it back to them of interest
and who he is beholden to because if
somebody has funded
his sofas and his bedding and the betty
sleeps in at night
we need to know whether that person has
an interest in government policy whether
that person
has an interest in winning government
contracts but the reason why
there's so many questions this morning
the reason why you're asking me
questions this morning
is because boris johnson still hasn't
offered a full and frank
explanation and we deserve transparency
because when you're the most powerful
politician
in the land we need to know who you are
beholden to
yeah but he he has said that or it has
been made known if it's come from him
directly to be fair
but the the prime minister has paid for
all of that refurb now out of his own
pocket
well we don't know that because
overnight we're hearing that
sorry the tory party had officers funded
it well donations so
we still don't have that but the
implication is if that
if that was the case it's been paid back
yeah but
but to whom so if you're the most
powerful politician in the land
and somebody's coming along and donating
to you
so you can buy a bed and a sofa and
cushions and rugs for your flat we need
to know who that is because we need to
know
what you then owe that business person
because if you're responsible i mean
we've seen so many contracts haven't we
go out to sort of uh tory party donors
in this crisis and so many business
people have got contracts which have
turned out for the ppe
and they turned out it was duff ppe we
had a contract going to somebody based
in
a jeweler based in miami who and all the
ppe they sent
wasn't up to scratch we need to know
this stuff we need to know
who the prime minister has obligations
to which is why you're supposed to
declare it all
in a ministerial register but he's not
done that so why hasn't he done that
people will assume he's got something to
hide
unless he offers that full and frank
explanation
do you think the public care i mean in
the sense that i mean therese coffee
again and
it's a valid point in the way saying
look people have got more to worry about
in their own lives particularly at the
moment
than what wallpapers going up in number
11. i think the public want politicians
to act with integrity and to be honest
if i walk down the street in leicester
and even if nobody
raises it with me as i walk down the
street in leicester
i still think it's important that
politicians here
fight for honesty and integrity in
public life
and that's what this is about if we're
not prepared to stand up for integrity
in public life
what is the point of being in politics
look you mentioned earlier on about the
the number of people on waiting lists in
the uk
on the nhs i mean you're putting forward
a recovery plan there's a very big
question as to
quite what you can do and if that
recovery plan is just going to put
an exponential amount of pressure on the
nhs staff
already strained to the very limit yeah
i mean that's a really really fair point
because our nhs staff have really been
through it haven't they
and they are facing i mean a lot of them
are facing trauma and burnout after the
year that they've had
but of course we've got these waiting
lists getting just growing getting
higher and higher and higher
and that will mean people will die
people will or people will be left with
permanent disability
so we need a plan to deal with this so
you've got to treat your staff properly
properly you've got to give them a fair
pay rise
for a start you've got to give them a
proper sort of
recuperation support and well-being
support but you've also got to get the
money into the nhs so you can start
bringing these waiting lists down again
as i say we've got the highest weights
on record now for children
with eating disorders we've got people
waiting longer for cancer treatment for
for treatment to do with that you know
heart problem treatments
people are going to die unless we get
something in place to deal with this
yeah but but again i'm want to push you
on on what i mean yeah a lot of people
are going to say yes they need a better
pay rise yes they need more support
but that doesn't speed up the process of
clearing a backlog
does it i mean what actually can you put
in place that is going to clear a
backlog more quickly well i'm not
underestimating the scale of the
challenge and you're clearly not going
to resolve this overnight
but it does start with funding properly
it starts with
funding equipment we have some of the
lowest numbers per head
of mri scanners ct scanners in the oecd
it starts with funding beds we've cut
around 15 000 beds
over the last 10 years in their nhs so
there are things you can do
to start bringing those waiting lists
down but but obviously
it's not going to happen overnight i'm
not going to be dishonest with the
british public on that but you've got to
make a start on it
because the longer we leave this the
worse this is going to get
okay jonathan ashraf good to talk to you
this morning thank you
now let's return to india where record
numbers of coronavirus cases
have left health services absolutely
on their knees well our special
correspondent alex crawford
joins us now from haryana state outside
of delhi
just what is the current situation alex
well there's still a very acute shortage
of
oxygen it seems across india
certainly one of the hospitals that we
went to yesterday
was telling us how they go hour to hour
really and they were
trying to get through the next six hours
and this morning
they put out yet another red flag
warning about
the shortage of oxygen these people here
have set up their own
impromptu very small but just trying to
do their bit
they traveled around the state they went
500 kilometers away to try to source
oxygen which they bought in
as many cylinders as they could it was
only about a dozen or so
and people have been camping out here
under the trees
just to get access to that oxygen many
of them
as we've been finding in many of these
places and and the number of the
hospitals that we visited have been
turned away
from hospitals even the government
hospitals the private hospitals
because they too are running short on
oxygen and clearly that's
put everyone in a very high state of
distress
delhi and india has posted yet more
record global record highs in the number
of coronavirus cases it dipped slightly
today
on the sixth day but it's still a global
record high in the spike of
of cases and international aid is
finally beginning to arrive the british
aid arrived this morning vital medical
supplies along with i understand about
20
oxygen ventilators well that's
grasped with great gratitude from the
people of india but clearly it's not
going to go
very far when you just have a quick look
here at just this small
little patch under trees and how many
people
are actually needing oxygen one woman
told us she'd been here
for two days already when clearly she
should probably be
in a hospital well one of the people who
are running it is ishan
singh let's try and have a quick quick
word with him ishan
you're live on on sky news tell me how
critical is the situation here and
how much trouble have you had in finding
oxygen
see if i talk about the ground situation
over here
we have patients who are waiting here
for two days they're not finding any
hospital
they just wanted oxygen because their
doctor has advice they have
they're on high antibiotics so that lady
over there if you see
she is here with our sons they rented a
car and they came here
two days back and still they cannot find
any
hospital they cannot find any bed they
are still here because their doctor
is advised if we see over there there's
a man behind me
he came here three days back he was fine
he went back again he came back
so his oxygen is going up and down
there's no medical facility proper
facility
yes and what do you think as as a as an
indian of this state of affairs when
it's reduced to
charities like yourself trying to
provide people with air
what do you think make of that as a as
an indian
actually it's not just about an indian i
being a sikh i can come from a sikh
religion
so we have always given the service to
people
starting from guru nanak dev ji our
first guru starting way back in 1469
so he gave free food to hungry people
and it started from there and when guru
gobind singh ji our tenth guru
he was in wars i don't mean to
interrupt you i totally understand the
history lesson i just wanted to get a
sense
as indians how desperate you're feeling
um clearly the sikhs have got a long
history in helping people but just a
a a global view on how desperate you're
feeling the
rest of the world is looking in on you
and seeing that you've got
the global record hides in coronavirus
cases and you're running out of basic
things like oxygen
actually the thing is over here we don't
see as a anyone is a stranger we all are
a family this lady over here i call her
as
my mother as my sister and everything
this part this
old man over here i call him as my
grandfather or father so i when i see my
family over here struggling for oxygen
strongly for medicines
i have to come here and i have to serve
my people that's what we feel
and our charity called himkun foundation
we started
ten years back in and in the lockdown
last year we were on the ground we were
delivering food and everything well
you're doing a great job thank you very
much ishan singh
from the hickman foundation one of many
who are set up to try and help
ordinary people because it doesn't
matter where you are throughout india
there seems to be
a real acute shortage of oxygen and that
is clearly having an
impact on on getting people better and
and a lot of people very suspicious
about the the numbers and questioning
whether they're absolutely accurate
they could be a lot worse okay alex
thank you
well let's talk to dr lance pinto as a
consultant respirologist at hinduja
hospital
in mumbai good to see you this morning
what is the situation like in the
hinduja hospital today
so fortunately the city of mumbai
doesn't seem to be facing the kind of
challenges that we've
heard from across the country we've not
really faced a situation
where oxygen levels have been low to
such an extent that we've had to
compromise patient care
ever so far and we have been constantly
reassured
that oxygen oxygen will be taken care of
it
we've been told to ration oxygen to be
sensible about how we use oxygen
uh but not once have we had to
compromise patient care
fortunately but i do realize this may
not be the the state of affairs in the
rest of the country
why do you think the country has got so
bad
i think nobody anticipated the scale or
the magnitude of
what we are facing right now i think all
of us
got a little complacent based on the
fact that the numbers uh
reduced to such low levels in the month
of january
that we thought that the worst was
behind us
i think covet 19 has been a lesson for
all countries across the world
that we need to be prepared for
escalation in healthcare
whenever the situation demands it and we
cannot be complacent about healthcare
and i think that's a universal lesson
that all countries across the world have
learned during this pandemic
in terms of of india's specific
requirements i mean clearly
you'll say you're in a better position
than most but but what is needed now i
mean
is it a supply of of oxygen is it
ventilators
is it vaccines what does india need the
most
so i think what we need are could be
split into what we need immediately and
clearly what we need immediately is
escalation and oxygen supplies
escalation and ventilators
bed availability to patients who
desperately need it and i think a lot
has been done i think there's a lot of
aid coming in from countries across the
world where we have oxygen tanks which
are being sent to us
we have compressed oxygen that's moving
across the country using
the country's railway system uh to get
it to the places that need it the most
i think the lockdowns have been extended
to a great extent there are hotels which
are being recruited
uh towards patient care um i think this
is the short-term
requirement which we really need
including ventilators and and thankfully
i think everybody is
is risen to the occasion in trying to
help india to the best of their
capacities
from a more long-term perspective of
course we need to escalate our
vaccination drive i think uh
one lesson that has been consistent
across the world is that
finally it's the vex it's it's
vaccination coverage it's universal
coverage
with vaccination that is going to help
us overcome the pandemic
and i think we need help in terms of
whatever supplies whatever
uh supply channels need to be in place
for us to be escalated to to be able to
escalate our vast vaccination production
and distribution
okay dr lance pinto it's good to torture
this morning thank you very much indeed
we'll bring you more on the escalating
situation in india in the next hour on
sky news breakfast